this
is star talk cosmic queries
this is the venus edition is there life
work
is there not and my co-host for this is
a
long time friend and sonny is all get
out paul mercurial paul
welcome back welcome back to star talk
dude thank you yeah it's been a while
it's great always fun
i was on i was on your podcast yes yeah
and the name of your podcast was the
paul mercurio show is that like the best
name you could come up with
well we workshopped it for six months
it's like we focus grouped it yeah
exactly
uh yeah it's on itunes and we got all
i i guess have an array of interesting
people so it's everybody from you to
paul mccartney kevin costner and oh
excuse me
name excuse me yeah i got people i got
to get people to go listen to it i got
to
no draft great so it's great to have you
on and so i you know i've
read about venus but i'm not an expert
on it
and so i had to call one of my old-time
friends and colleagues
david grinspoon dr funky spoon
david welcome back to star talk thanks
neil it's it's great to see you and
always
always fun to uh to do star talk is your
twitter handle still dr funky spoon
oh yeah yeah i'm i am dr funky spoon on
twitter
okay and you're also a part-time
musician
uh i guess this is you you you you
ripped some lines
about was it the big bang or planets on
an
earlier episode well we did we did the
astrobiology blues
basketballs
yeah especially these days when we're
all kind of uh stuck stuck at home i've
been i've been playing a little bit
right excellent i see a guitar in your
back back there
and uh where are you now in this moment
in washington dc in my uh
in an undisclosed location in a basement
also in your parents basement okay
let the record show he hasn't moved out
he still hasn't launched
like that scene with uh with uh the will
farrell mom
meatloaf and he just screams
hey you're making me hungry so uh but
anyhow you've
um literally wrote the book on venus a
few years back
the book venus revealed so venus is one
of your
planetary objects of affection uh as a
working scientist at the planetary
science institute based in arizona but
you're
in a satellite location there in
washington dc so just welcome back to
star talk
thanks yeah venus has been an obsession
of mine uh
you know since graduate school um and so
it's always fun when you see it uh when
i see it get get a little extra
attention
well what we did was we solicited as we
always do for cosmic queries questions
from our
fan base on all the various social media
platforms about venus about the
possibility of life on venus
and just but paul and paul you have all
those questions right so i haven't i
haven't seen him i don't know
david you haven't seen them either have
you i have not yeah yeah so he's gonna
he's gonna pull out the hard ones
[Laughter]
okay this is for a new car
wait wait before you begin i just want
to just establish this so david you've
been a planetary guy your whole life
yeah i've been doing research projects
with uh paul mccartney and kevin costner
no
yeah i i i have i mean literally my
whole life in the sense that
even as a kid um you know like a lot of
uh uh scientists my
generation after the the moonlighting
that was it i was gonna be a space
person in some way and then i
was uh pretty much obsessed with
planetary exploration as a teenager all
the
first missions were going out to you
know venus and mars and stuff and then
um undergraduate grad school uh
planetary science researcher it's uh you
know that's that's been my
my thing my literally pretty much my
whole life okay paul might be your age
and
so he had the same moon landing
experience but he didn't
become a scientist so paul what's what
happened to you
wow i gotta go
if i want to be heckled i'll do the 2 30
spot at the comedy center
i don't need this the background no wait
exactly
exactly well in fifth grade i made a
solar system out of styrofoam balls so
there
okay there you go okay no i you know i
i it's just never been i like science i
just
wasn't i didn't feel like that was sort
of mine you have good science literacy
otherwise you wouldn't keep inviting you
back just
so you know i do thank you yeah i do
enjoy it i do read up on it and
uh so and i and when i leave these shows
i always
feel both dumber and smarter at the same
time so that's a good thing actually
yeah
yeah that's a good thing yeah so you
know that you don't know everything and
you're proud of what you do now
yeah exactly the place to be so paul
what do you have for us
okay here we go first one is uh from uh
patreon uh
izzy rohr so much about venus is still a
mystery to us and since
our early reference point for the life
for life is earth-based
isn't it hard to say that the phosphine
found on venus is a sign of life
could it just as easily be caused by
something that we
never encountered before and so wouldn't
even know to think of
what do you make of it whoa
so there david yeah no i mean that's a
great question
i mean you know start off by starting
but by giving a
three-minute two-minute overview of that
of that press conference and
what news that we're all reacting to
here yeah so the big news
this week uh is that um it was
announced that um a
a discovery was made about venus um
which
is that a gas called phosphine was
detected
in the atmosphere of venus um using two
different radio telescopes on earth
um a spectroscopic signal a line an
absorption line
that shouldn't be in the atmosphere of
venus and they couldn't
find any other gas that would explain it
except for this gas called phosphine
which is just a phosphorus atom with
three
hydrogen atoms hanging off it a simple
molecule which on earth
is only produced in our atmosphere
basically by life or by industrial
processes
including meth labs but nobody's saying
hey there's meth labs on venus but
but um you know this pole is pretty sure
yeah probably we'll
we'll go there for sure by the way i
hope this leads to an outer space reboot
of breaking bad that's all i want to see
happen
i think it needs to happen so so so this
is a surprising result because
phosphine is a chemical that should not
be in the atmosphere of venus
meaning that if some of it if you just
put some in the atmosphere of venus you
would expect it to go away very quickly
because the other chemicals there you
would expect them to to eat it it's not
stable there
and so this is a known way of searching
for
life on well on exoplanets especially
planets around other stars where you can
only look at the atmospheres
because the idea is that if something
is producing an unexpected gas in an
atmosphere it could be a sign of life
and so there's this unexpected gas in
the atmosphere of venus which on earth
is only
made by life and so the scientists have
said well what if
could it be volcanoes and they did
calculations and they said no there's no
way it could be volcanoes could it be
cosmetics
venus has volcanoes venus does have
volcanoes so that's an obvious thought
but it
you know if they've done their
calculations right and you can be sure
all of this is going to be scrutinized
you know it ought to be scrutinized you
know is there a problem with the
observation maybe
it did they do their calculations wrong
maybe there's some obvious way
to make the phosphine they're not
thinking of but you know at this point
it seems like a big mystery why this
biogenic gas
is is in the atmosphere of venus so
but but you know the question um is well
taken because yes absolutely
um it could be a sign of something else
that we haven't
figured out yet it's just that simply
that nobody has yet
figured out a good way to make it that's
not life so that doesn't mean
oh we've fought it doesn't mean oh we
found life on venus it means we found
this mysterious
indicator that has been um
before this discovery it was already
published the idea that if you found
phosphine in an atmosphere
uh it could be a sign of life so so
there it is isn't one theory
that this life i mean it's 800 degrees
on venus but somehow some of it got into
the atmosphere
of venus which is more life-friendly
it'd be like 85
degrees fahrenheit i was reading in that
atmosphere and that's where it sort of
has maybe taken hold yeah paul that's a
very important point because
you know anybody listening to this who
knows you know
basic um facts about the solar system
knows that venus is not a place you
would expect
life because the surface is is 900
degrees fahrenheit and it's you know
it's hell there so
why are we even talking about this but
there's a layer
up in the atmosphere about 35 miles up
where there are cl permanent global
cloud decks and it's rather
comfortable at least in terms of
temperature and pressure it's like earth
surface
conditions and there are you know
potential flows of nutrients and energy
and you know all the stuff you might
need for life up there
and that's part of you know what this is
this idea that i've been pushing for a
while it's like hey there could be a
habitable zone up in the venus
atmosphere
and uh could you just go up with a
mirror and see if there's any fog on the
mirror and then that's life form you
know like a dead body kind of a thing
that's the old days yeah
paul how old are you that's that was a
19th century way to know if someone was
dead
i'm 100 i'm 106 years old there it is
because if you fog the mirror that was
evidence you're still alive well you
know we're looking we're looking hard
for techniques to go go there and test
this so all suggestions are uh you know
we'll put that one in the uh mirror
just in case you never know
wait wait so so david if i don't know if
you're a betting man but let me just ask
you
what are the chances it's actually life
versus
a completely yet to be discovered way
to make phosphine that no one is dreamt
of yet
yeah man it's how do you balance this
because both are extraordinary
yeah right because we think we think we
got a good chemistry we
you know we've been doing chemistry
forever right we think we got that
so where do you if you're a betting man
where would you put it
yeah boy it's hard to put a number on it
i mean you know there's there's a third
likely possibility
which unfortunately which is that maybe
the observation is wrong and it's it's
very difficult
inference and i mean to me it seems as
though it's very solid work the way
they've described it but you know people
are going to be looking really hard and
trying to repeat the observation and
maybe the phosphine will go away because
it'll say oh well actually it's
something else or it was
was a mistake but let's assume that
there really is phosphine there
what are the chances it's life uh you
know
so people keep asking me that it's so
hard to put a number on it so yesterday
um on facebook i said i'm gonna say five
percent but i'll probably change my mind
tomorrow
and you know i reserve the right to to
have a very fluid opinion of this
because
we just don't know and of course you
have to you know our friend carl sagan
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence and if there was
ever
a place where this applied you know we
need better evidence
much more evidence more evidence before
we say oh life but
this is a legitimate mystery that has a
legitimate
um you know logical um
path to infer that it could be life and
you know whether that's one percent or
ten percent i don't know
but it's you know it's it's less than 50
it's more likely that it's something
else but it's not zero that it's life
and that in itself is
is a pretty exciting thing to realize
and just for people to recognize
when you have results that are
interesting and unexpected
they naturally attract more scientific
scrutiny to see if it's correct
so that that's a very natural urge that
we all have that's
in fact paul it's a problem if you get a
result that's
not particularly interesting and wrong
very few people will find out that it's
wrong because they don't care
so the verification process is not a
level playing field
right if you make a really interesting
mistake then everybody's gonna know
about it
all right so what else you got people
move on okay uh philip lyons patreon my
question is simple when can we get a
sample
and bring it back to earth to be studied
i think you can get it on amazon
you got to be a you got to be a prime
member and yeah and they deliver
tomorrow
exactly no it's actually august or
somebody's 2032.
somebody's selling them on ebay right
now but i wouldn't you know give it a
lot of uh
you know credence um but so that does
leave the question like
which i was thinking is sort of this is
a two is this a two a parallel track
issue of
you make this discovery but then you
also have to create or invent a way
to kind of confirm this or sort of get
to the next level with this so do you
have to
develop processes and techniques oh yeah
at the same time no very much there
we need follow-up uh experiments i mean
first of all just
in in on earth in labs people are going
to be going crazy saying well let's mix
phosphine in a venus-like environment
and put this and then
can we do it how else can we make it
just here on earth
trying to simulate it but you can be
sure that we are going to be sending
i mean we've been trying to some of us
have been trying to send new missions to
venus
anyways and there's momentum and i think
this is going to be happening
even i would have said that even before
this discovery but now there's that much
more incentive
we've got to go there and understand uh
what's going on there
now bringing back a sample would not be
the next step
that's a hard thing to do uh you know
it's hard enough to bring back a rock
from mars which you know we've been
trying for a long time and we're still
trying and there's something in the
works but it's not
it's not very easy but an atmospheric
sample from a
you know think about it you're going to
enter into the atmosphere you're going
to scoop something up and then you're
going to
launch not from a surface but from an
aerial platform
and it's inherently harder to get
something off venus than mars because
it's a bigger planet with more escape
gravity or you know with more gravity
higher escape velocity so
that i think probably will be done
eventually but the next step
is actually to just go there and do
experiments in place
bring the right scientific instruments
into the atmosphere and the clouds
to investigate and send the data back
rather than trying to bring a sample
back
david you're not talking about rovers
because this is 35 miles
up in the atmosphere so you need some
kind of floater yeah yeah i mean well i
mean even
you know the easiest thing to do um is
just drop an entry probe and you're
briefly traveling through that
environment
and you take measurements on the way
down that's been done but not
in the 21st century with modern
instrumentation and that you can still
learn a lot even with a quick trip
through with the right instrument
sending back data but then
uh as you as you say neil it would be
even better to
bring a platform where you could reside
in the clouds for a while either a
balloon
or um some kind of a solar powered
glider there are
plans and ideas to do this and i think
you know a balloon would be
great because then you could actually
spend some time and sample more than one
location
and you know really look around and get
to know the environment a little bit
rather than just
flying through it i have a quick
question related to this so
if the heat weren't the issue is
pressure on the surface also
an issue here because it's 90 times that
of earth
so you have to grapple with that at the
same time
is the heat issue in terms of trying to
find the sample right and paul's showing
off that he did his homework before
yeah yeah i i i have my sixth grade
science teacher sitting off to the side
right here and he's because he said he's
signing me well it's got 90 times their
pressure
that's pretty good yeah that's pretty
good that's pretty good yeah no i mean
that that's yet another reason why the
surface environment is
a um you know a very challenging
environment
both for life to survive and for our
machines to survive if we gonna want to
go investigate it
which we should i mean the mystery of
venus even if we're talking about a
mystery up in the clouds
it's related to surface processes
because i mean one of the things that
that makes venus such an interesting
planet is that it seems to have an
active surface
and that's connected to the chemistry of
the clouds they're
active you mean geologically active yeah
geologically active and that
seems to include active volcanoes which
is really important for this story
although
you know i say seems to include we've
got a lot of circumstantial evidence we
don't have what they they call the
smoking gun where we've seen a volcano
going off but
there are clues in the atmosphere and
the smoking volcano
yes exactly the smoking caldera we don't
have that
but but we do have we see things in the
atmosphere and patterns on the surface
that make
the most sense if there is active
volcanism so we think there probably
is on venus but we we want to confirm
that but it's important to this story
because
it's probable that the chemistry
whatever's going on in the clouds
has to do with gases that are coming out
of the circle and
cycling through the atmosphere and then
reacting with surface rocks
so just as on earth we talk about the
carbon cycle and these these different
chemical cycles
on venus there's a sulfur cycle and
probably other sulfur cycles
involving the clouds in the atmosphere
and the surface
so if we want to understand what's going
on in the atmosphere ultimately we do
have to investigate the surface
but is that what you wouldn't need you
wouldn't need a rover or something like
that to do a dedicated mission just to
to look at what's going on up in the
cloud so if there's a sulfur cycle
that's where you get
i've always read that venus has sulfuric
acid droplets in the upper atmosphere
and i always wondered
you know how they get there why don't we
have some of that and so
it's got a sulfur cycle huh yeah i mean
interestingly we do have some of that
and when when there's a big volcano
volcanic eruption on earth and you get
those colorful sunsets and sometimes
there's even a temporary cooling
because that stuff spreads through the
stratosphere that's actually
mostly sulfuric acid droplets that you
get a little bit of temporarily on earth
and but on venus of course the clouds
are
almost all sulfuric acid and we believe
that
is related to volcanic flow from the
surface again this is something we want
to verify with with more investigations
and missions but uh calculations that
actually which
which uh i did with with my research
team several years ago
where we tried to look at at the
lifetime of the cloud particles
we actually believed that the clouds
would go away in about 10 million years
or maybe 30 million years if they
weren't
continually fueled by a flow of sulfuric
gases from the surface which if that's
true it's pretty cool because it means
that when you go out at night
and you observe venus with your naked
eyes and you see how beautiful and
bright it is
you're actually observing the effect of
volcanoes on the surface
because that the reason why venus is so
cloudy and so bright and you can see
that
on any any given evening or morning when
venus is in the right place
that is connected we believe to an
ongoing
existence of volcanoes so so so you can
verify that with that with your senses
is there anything here on earth like
sulfur springs that we can use that we
use or can use
to advance our knowledge to work in this
capacity in the context of venus and
phosphine and all of that
we gotta get to that answer after this
break okay
so paul mercurial wants to know if
they're sulfur creatures
it's in hot springs on earth when star
trek returns cosmic queries the venus
edition
we're back cosmic query the venus
edition life on venus edition
paul mercurio my co-host paul
dude we have david grinsmoon this this
is like i
i feel like i should be this should be
like a master class that series and i
should be paying money or something this
is amazing
you'll get our bill that's fine but when
right when we left uh you had a question
this wasn't from our list right
you posed the question yeah uh whether
our sulfur springs
can help us understand sulfur conditions
on venus
yeah yeah enormous in any way it's very
very relevant
to to this whole story because uh
you know one of the ways we try to
understand where in the universe there
may be
potential for life is by looking at the
range of conditions that
life can inhabit on earth and as we've
learned more and more about what we call
these extremophile organisms the lovers
of extremes we realize that
it's a much wider range of conditions
than we once thought
and there's a whole category of
extremophiles that are that are
acidophiles
that that we've discovered organisms
that love to live in strong acid
including
acid hot springs uh of the kind you
mentioned and that's one of the reasons
why some of us think that you know we
shouldn't
fully count out the clouds of venus as a
habitat now it's true the clouds of
venus are more acidic
than the places on earth so far that we
found
um acid-loving organisms but we do not
know really what the extreme limit of
of of uh how acidic an environment can
be
and support life and so people that are
interested in these questions they study
that environment you mentioned the acid
hot springs you know they
go on field trips to places like
yellowstone and they look for
uh life that lives in these uh these
extreme environments that are at least
more venus-like than than other places
on earth so david when
when tourists go take hot baths in these
sulfur springs
would you consider those humans
extremophiles
i'm just wondering yeah yeah absolutely
i mean i guess i can i love hot springs
and so i guess uh
next time i'm i'm in one i should
contemplate the fact that i don't know
yes i think it depends if they're
wearing a bathing suit or not if they're
not wearing a bathing suit
there you go they are very bold people
yeah
uh should we move on yeah yeah paul keep
going paul's got any questions this is
mcquarries
this is vincent zimmerman on twitter is
there life in the clouds of venus what
liquid is that life using on earth we
use
water as solvent i think it's sorak
vodka isn't it
that's right uh no it's sort of related
to what we're talking about
an extension of that yeah no i mean
absolutely i mean one of the challenges
is as far as we know life needs water
and that as far as we know has to be
emphasized because maybe we're just not
being imaginative enough and
and you know so much about the universe
we learn through
exploration not through modeling and
expecting what we're going to find and
uh you know wait so is it that life
needs water or that life needs
a liquid yeah well that's a great
question so
so you could look at it both ways um the
chemistry of life you could think of
life
you know on earth as this dance of
organic molecules which take advantage
of the fact they're in liquid so they
can do this
you know 3d coming together and um doing
all the
the complex interactions that molecules
do it's hard to imagine that happening
not in a liquid medium
uh and people have said well what about
ammonia or this or that or
you know it's an interesting question
although nobody's come up with a full
theory of how that would work
maybe that's just i saw a comic it might
have been the new yorker where there's
the alien crash lands in the desert and
it's crawling along the dunes and it
says
ammonia ammonia yeah exactly
exactly yeah so so are we just being uh
geocentric when we say life needs water
yeah this is one
centric yeah this is one of the
hydrocentric this is one of the great
questions
with all of your fancy water
and you know this this is one of the big
motivations for finding alien life i
mean of course
the biggest motivation is just we want
to know are we alone but in terms of the
science once we
have multiple samples then we could
start to really address this question is
it all
basically the same chemically or are
there completely other bases
so most of what we do is search for
water-based life
um when we think about astrobiology and
other environments maybe that's just our
narrow-mindedness but you got to start
somewhere and we at least know how life
and water
would work now sulfuric acid is kind of
a borderline case because
in a certain sense it is water with just
a lot of
um acid mixed in it's a it's a
concentrated mix of
you know it's it's water with the
sulfuric acid
molecules and so in a certain sense the
clouds of venus
are uh are strictly speaking a water
environment it's just that we don't know
of life that can live in water that's
that polluted
with a strong acid you know so would it
be life as we know it
uh it's borderline it would have to be
life that had evolved these sort of
mechanisms to maybe pump its interior
free
of of acid or a different kind of
chemistry that can work with those acid
molecules
so but in response to the question there
is plenty of
liquid there's plenty of liquid there
and that's one of the things that makes
some of us uh you know not want to
rule out that environment uh twitter uh
at doodle whoopsie uh
whoopsie doodle whoopsie yeah or a big
fan of the show apparently yes
exactly it's whoopsie doodle doo doo doo
doo
whoopsie apparently i guess at whoopsie
doodle was taken already so they had to
flip it anyway
uh hi doctor they're living backwards in
time leads forward to them
exactly what is the most basic and
trusted way to search
life in the universe oh that's a great
question of course
there's a lot of effort going into
answering that but interestingly
the most common answer you would
probably get now
especially because we have discovered
exoplanets and we want to know what
they're like and if they might have
life all the planets around other stars
that we can't just send a spacecraft to
you know in in a few months it would
take a few centuries so
so we have to rely on remote
observations and the best way
is to search for weird gases anomalous
gases
in the atmosphere like phosphine for
instance
so um you know what just to be clear
it's not
just that they're weird gases they're
gases associated with the existence of
life
yeah yeah weird in a particular way
that's right um out of equilibrium
things that
shouldn't shouldn't be in the atmosphere
and are plausibly
associated with some kind of biological
metabolism
but paul did you know that humans and
life in general
is hugely out of equilibrium with its
environment did anybody ever tell you
that
no what does that mean
you know are you really just talking
about me that i'm not
with the rest of them it's not just you
if you've been wondering we're all out
of equilibrium
so just think about it i mean the air
around you let's say 72 degrees and your
body temperature is
27 degrees warmer than that and it stays
that way that's not an equilibrium with
your environment
what a challenge for us be able to exist
in that way if we're out of equilibrium
you keep eating
yeah you regulate your internal
environment and you put energy into that
but also earth yeah by the way if i if i
stop giving you food
you will eventually be you'll
you will die and you'll reach the
temperature of the air and then you'll
be in equilibrium is that what you want
paul uh yeah i think i do
uh no and all your molecules will
oxidize
i mean the thing is earth itself is not
an
equilibrium state if you were an alien
looking at our atmosphere you'd say
what's all that oxygen doing there and
what are these traces of methane doing
there
and you know there are things in our
atmosphere that would not be there on a
lifeless earth
and that's the idea that we we learn to
understand
what life does to its atmosphere and
then we search for those signs
elsewhere so those those greenhouse
gases are
knocking that this whole this our
environment and the people are living it
more out of equilibrium then right
because sort of we're not in the natural
state of yeah not just greenhouse gases
but some of them are greenhouse gases
which is very interesting because then
life starts to interact with the climate
of a planet methane
you know i mentioned is a greenhouse gas
and it is um at least
uh partly on earth a product of life and
then you get to this these weird
potential mechanisms where life can feed
back
on the planet and do things like change
its own climate
what is the is is there a there is there
a basic or trusted way
not necessarily there are a lot i mean
do you list define life i mean do you
leave food out overnight
like treats and if someone comes and get
it then you know there's life like what
no what is there to address whoopsie
doodles uh
question is there something how about
this david
if you just rank the gas's top three uh
that would be the most tantalizing
suggestion that there was like what
would it be
um oxygen which is not
a hundred percent because there are
natural you know non-biological ways to
make oxygen but if we saw a planet with
as much oxygen as earth we'd go wait a
minute what's going on there and
at least you consider life well methane
is a good one
again not there are other ways to make
it but you know we find little wisps of
methane on mars and we go hmm what what
is that and
life is at least one possibility but
there are others and i would actually
um farm animal farm animals on that's
right mars
yeah cow farts yeah they're cows on what
mars cows but but interestingly um
uh phosphine is potential just to be
clear wait wait david just to be clear
uh paul i don't know if you knew this
right so methane is the byproduct of
anaerobic metabolism which goes on in
the guts of animals
right especially in ruminants right like
cows
and methane is the gas that's the gas of
choice in
cities for gas stoves so
that old camp thing that you always
wanted to do
to see with a lighter if it's flammable
yeah it's really true
you know i tried i did i tried that on
the subway and got arrested for it
so apparently you're not supposed to do
that on the subway at least
you were doing it uh doing atmospheric
disequilibrium experiments officer i'm
officer i'm a scientist i'm just trying
to explore the universe more
i'm sure that was very effective yeah
but but so top three oxygen methane and
then you know quite possibly phosphine
um is in that top three it's been you
know they've been pa
before this discovery on venus there
were papers that were published saying
that phosphine is an ideal
biosignature gas an ideal sign of life
because
it's hard to come up with mechanisms to
make it
on a rocky planet that are not
biological now you can be sure
you know every chemist on earth since
monday is now uh
trying to come up with new ways to make
phosphine and you know if if we don't
learn about life
on venus from this we will learn new
things about chemistry on venus because
uh somebody's gonna figure out some
other way to make phosphine that we
didn't know
but but right now you know it's in the
literature
as a very promising biosignature gas
that if you found it on an
exoplanet you'd say hey wait a minute
this could be a sign of life
so it's pretty wild to find that gas
right right here on the planet next door
and just to be clear the rover that's on
route to mars right now
perseverance so let's just call it percy
percy
i like that so just to be clear paul we
can look at the chemistry of the
atmosphere of these exoplanets
or you know if an alien comes out from
under a rock and rides the rover
that would be that would count as
evidence too like
wouldn't it david yeah yeah no i mean
it's it's true i mean
you know the question is it's really
they're taking
it's a really good question what's the
best way to find life and you know we
focus a lot on these gases that we could
find on exoplanets because that's all
you can do on exoplanets right now but
absolutely
when we send um instruments with with
cameras uh it's worth looking on a place
like mars
you know especially the first the first
ever landers on mars you know carl sagan
used to talk about well we should at
least take pictures and see if there's a
turtle walking by
you know because who knows or even look
for look for turtle tracks in the sand
maybe there's like a probe from another
planet or venus and in it is a
their version of a chuck berry song so
then
exactly we know that there's like
we gotta take a quick break and we'll be
back with our third and final segment
of star talk cosmic queries the venus
edition
we're back star talk cosmic prairie the
venus edition
uh paul mccarron my co-host paul what's
your twitter handle
at paul mercurio m-e-c-u-r-i-o one-armed
very
creative yes
i'm sorry i can't be
whoopsie-doodle-doodle-dude you know
all right so paul give me some more matt
hairfield patreon
how do you think life would have evolved
under the conditions on venus do you
do does venus have liquid water at some
point
did venus have liquid water at some
point quick answer so we're back in time
dave yeah
go back in time yeah what are we talking
about quick answer we think venus had
oceans when it was younger
we're not exactly sure how long they
lasted but they might have lasted for
billions of years
and then the idea is probably if there
was an evolution of life it started
and and advanced on the surface and then
when that surface
broke bad um then maybe it ended up in
the atmosphere
i mean if i mean if there was life and
it did evolve it had with the harsh
conditions it had to be complaining like
the whole time like ah it's so hot i
can't go out
oh where's my with their runaway
greenhouse effect they just burned too
many fossil fuels that's what they that
was their problem
well that you know actually that was
irresponsible venusians man
well interesting david i didn't thought
of that if there was life on the surface
and that became inhospitable and they
had some way to
fly then they could just continue to
ascend away from the heat
and so far we know there's whole
floating cities in this layer of the
atmosphere where they found the
phosphine yeah i mean we're starting
with the hypothesis of of microbes but
we don't actually have observations that
would rule out something
much more complex and so in the movie
avatar they had floating islands
[Laughter]
recently um this is a stupid completely
irrelevant comment
but you know the flintstones pioneered
chewable vitamins right for kids and
they still salt for sale
and i thought to myself they're the
stone age they wouldn't have known
anything about vitamins but the jetsons
would have
so there really should have been jet
chewable vitamins that's what i'm
thinking that's very profound neil
that felt a little uh passive aggressive
hi paul give me some more what do you
got we will go to uh
ashley uh steadly on facebook
could these be the same extra
extremophiles that were on
early earth if these are microbes or
bacteria what might happen if we brought
some to earth
two good questions um yeah dave if we go
to venus with a sample return
and oh my gosh there are bugs and there
are microbes that doesn't sound very
very wise yeah yeah i mean
with uh we always um consider what we
call planetary protection when we talk
about sample returns especially from a
possibly
inhabited environment you know how do
you uh be really sure you're not
bringing something back that could be
dangerous and so you know there are
protocols where you just you
keep it in a contained environment at
first
but if you're talking about life in the
clouds of venus i think
you know of course you always want to be
cautious but that seems like less of a
consideration because it's such an
extreme environment it doesn't seem like
it would very easily
overlap environments on earth that are
inhabited
so it's probably the case that if some
if there were venetian bugs in an
extreme
extreme extreme acid environment and
they sort of got out of your laboratory
that they would
not do well and not be able to um hurt
any
multiply and hurt anything on earth
that's my first reaction but i also
think you know you just
you're we're inherently cautious about
these things
um as far as far as the first part of
the question um could these be similar
to
life on early earth it's possible
but you know we don't know that much
about the environment of early earth and
it's true that some of the
theories of origin of life involve hot
springs
on early earth but probably not as
extremely acidic so i want to say
they're not it's not my picture of the
first life
on earth but on the other hand we're
still very ignorant about what that
early life
was was like and so it's not it's not
impossible
it's fair to say that if you brought a
venus bug here it would say
oh it's not acid enough i'm dying i'm
melting i need more acid
is that would it pull a wicked witch of
the west on us but
it would but it would say it in venusian
so
[Laughter]
well you know i don't know about the
three i mean like if it's anything i i
lived in dc and when i moved back home i
brought
cockroaches with me and man all hell
broke loose so like
maybe they have cockroaches they seem to
live everywhere
that's a good example of why we uh do uh
planetary protection
yeah and and uh well this also by the
way could be a movie the three of us
should pitch like venus
you know microbes come to earth and it's
a movie and paul giamatti is like the
misunderstood
clever brilliant scientist who's the
only one that sees the problem like that
i think that's a movie we should pitch
but
so apologiamati is playing me
sorry about that i just want to pursue
the wicked witch of the west scenario
again
i mean think about it presumably they
only poured a bucket of water on her
and water is is acidically neutral
correct
so if she yeah that's a good point why
did water make her melt
right and i'm saying because she she
must not be acidically neutral she's
either
very acidic or very um basic
in either direction she's far away from
what water would do she was from venus
she was from venus she was actually the
wicked witch of venus
i thought there was something
extremophile about her i really did
and it and it's evidence that aliens are
green just to put that one to so maybe
there's flying monkeys there too
right boy those scared the heck out of
me when oh my god
everybody didn't they i mean i'm like
why this isn't fun
you can't list this as a comedy like
what is this this is like
it was the worst it's like you got a
green woman no fashion sense the witch
had no fashion sense it was either all
black or way over the top with jewels
flippers
don't get me started all right uh we'll
go to another one
paul i didn't know you still had issues
i do
no one i need a hug uh i need a venusian
hug
uh all right we're gonna go to another
one all right all right here we go yeah
let's get to them quick okay here we go
see as many as we can do okay
uh this is uh instagram sam z uh hi dr
tyson and dr david so if venus is a
terrestrial planet
then why is the atmosphere's pressure so
high also you mentioned in a previous
video that saturn protects us
from asteroids and stuff what if
anything does venus do for us
okay personally i wouldn't have said
saturn i would have said jupiter that
jupiter has all the
the good gravity out there to to bat
wayward comets and asteroids out of
harm's way
but david yeah
why why is our twin sister planet so
different from us
yeah so i mean he said if venus is a
terrestrial planet well terrestrial
planet uh really just means a rocky
planet
um you know like venus earth mars
mercury
and um they can have all different kinds
of atmospheres we've learned that just
in our solar system and we imagine if
you included the terrestrial planets
out there in the galaxy to be even more
diverse but the reason why
venus's atmosphere is so thick we think
has to do
actually with the very high temperature
in a kind of
feedback where once it gets that hot
it's hard to remove gases the reason why
earth doesn't have
that much carbon dioxide in its
atmosphere is because there's a cycle a
carbon cycle
where carbon dioxide over time gets
removed from the atmosphere and turned
into carbonate rocks
that cycle depends on water and rainfall
where the water gets dissolved in
rainfall and runs over the rocks and
reacts and ends up
some of that carbon ends up as as ions
in the ocean and then gets precipitated
on the surface
and then ends up in the interior there's
this whole complex cycle
on earth where carbon is removed from
the atmosphere
but if you take an earth and you dry it
out so there's no surface water and no
rainfall
then the carbon dioxide's still coming
out of the volcanoes over and over
millions of years it's going to build up
but you've sort of broken the part of
the cycle where the water helps you
remove
the carbon from the atmosphere so we
think that's what's happened on venus is
that once it lost its surface water
it still kept accumulating carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere but now
there's sort of no way to pull it out
because you don't have those chemical
reactions mediated by water
so it's sort of stuck with all this uh
atmosphere and no place to put it
is there any of this any understanding
why the water on venus
disappeared is it haven't we been able
to figure that out at all
well it's it's a you know so there's
this idea of the runaway greenhouse
where what because water itself is a
greenhouse gas it absorbs
infrared radiation so you add water
vapor to a planet and it's going to heat
up
so um then you can have this feedback
where if if
there's a certain amount of sunlight
hitting a planet
like venus that has that used to have
oceans presumably
then that evaporates some of the ocean
which increases the amount of water
vapor in the atmosphere
which heats up the planet more which
then evaporates more of the ocean so
it can kind of run away so that may be
why venus lost its oceans although
we're still sort of really trying to
figure out that history and it's of
course it's the details get complicated
and are
are debated well basically you're saying
the aliens on venus had a terrible
energy policy and when it hit 500
degrees they should have done something
about it but they totally ignored it
that's what you're saying they totally
say do not let this happen to your
planet
have astrobiology this is david hemseth
uh
hemsath at patreon have astrobiologists
previously tried mapping earth's
extremophiles to venus's environments
oh let's make that a bigger question
david all the earth's extreme files can
we find a place for every one of them
in in the local solar system or even
across the galaxy
wow that's that's that is a much bigger
question
that would be a fun exercise actually
take take the whole map of all the
extremophiles and then
um take either real or imagined planets
and say this is the planet where these
guys would be at home and here's what
its qualities are i don't know of
anybody that's done that neil so we
should we should talk that'd be a fun
thing to do
as far as mapping specific extremophiles
to venus
uh people have tried and there are
organisms that sort of get us closer
there i mentioned acidophilus
loving organisms we as far as we
understand the clouds of venus and their
conditions and again this is
a region that we need to explore more
carefully there's no
known earth organism that you could just
plunk there and it would be
be happy and say i love it here and just
multiply and keep living
but there are organisms that sort of get
us part way there that are
resistant to ultraviolet light and that
are um
that can exist in in strong acid and
um you know there's a big effort now
also to figure out what's living in
earth's clouds
because there are organisms in earth
clouds but we still don't understand
their sort of
entire life cycles so so there's an area
of investigation where we do look at
extremophiles and try to map them into
venus's uh conditions but nobody sort of
nailed it and said ah here's this bug
that would love it there
i saw that episode of watchmen where a
squid come from the sky
this is it it rained squid in one of the
episodes
just but aren't there actual actual
historical
um recountings of like frogs raining
from the skies and
and you know weird um episodes maybe
there's something
maybe there's a whole biota in a layer
of the atmosphere
and we're discounting these legends and
these mythological accounts
but in fact it's another place it's like
odds it's beyond
the reality of what we accept next week
on the history channel
[Laughter]
squid squid nato
and you and neil are fighting squids
falling from the sky
inexplicably and you've got guns and
lasers
we got two yeah we've got two movies
we've got to pitch now there's a lot to
do
should we do one more uh
uh ishaan ishanbasi and instagram there
uh there have been a few venus missions
in past although none of them survived
for very long
is there a slight possibility
possibility that they might have
introduced this life form
into the atmosphere of venus quick
answer i'm going to say
no because um
you know when something falls into the
atmosphere of venus it's surrounded by a
bald
fire before anything and then there's
this
this basic fact that the conditions are
just so different that it's hard to
imagine
something um leaping off a spacecraft
and surviving
come on not like a discarded taco bell
cup nothing there's gonna be something
plastic supermarket shopping bags come
on
well wait wait david viruses get around
you know
i mean viruses invented people
so that people would invent airplanes so
that viruses can go transcontinental
and infect more people that's true but
viruses that so we could have
darwinian evolution accounting so we
could have dumped some viruses
accidentally on venus but viruses don't
live
without other cells to invade so i still
don't think the viruses would be
thriving there and doesn't your answer
presuppose
it's sort of the lack of knowledge we
have which is
uh infinite right so in other words we
don't know if there
is some form of life that could drop
into that atmosphere
and survive because we don't really
understand it yet i mean you asked for
the short version of the answer the
longer version is like
well caveat caveat caveat who knows
maybe this may be that but
paul stopped leading him off all right
sorry okay i'm sorry
he's trying to stretch this answer out
all right
all right let's go one one more a quick
one okay all right here we go
uh and tomorrow david i want a one word
answer to this one whatever it is i
don't care
okay tomorrow life instagram can life
and venus exist in the
animal ballpark or just as microbes
slash bacteria
no maybe
excellent we got to stop it at the maybe
paul always good to have you always a
lot of fun i always learned something
thank you for having me
and david don't be such a stranger dude
it's been too long yeah
on the show it's true uh especially when
this uh when this pandemic is over we
gotta uh
go out for a glass of wine yeah and
we'll get you to play some more
uh alien blues uh i'm i'm ready
okay acid loving venusian blues
that's it love it venetian blues this
has been star talk cosmic prairie venus
edition i'm will degrasse tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist
you